Vinh was coming in for his first day of
shooting in there we've done a bunch of
like setups working whatnot and it's
unpleasant so everyone is wearing like
sort of the equivalent of like a hazmat
suit in there and and so now my gosh can
we can we sort of maybe lose the masks
for a minute or two because it's very
difficult to convince someone to shoot
in this for - hi I'm Vin Diesel and I'm
Dave Wilson and we're gonna do a ski and
breakdown for you bloodshot all right
I'm gonna pause here just to give a
little context of all of this so no one
would let us shut a tunnel down for the
two weeks we were filming this so we
built the whole thing in South Africa we
filmed the whole movie it is this
awesome massive set that we built that
we filled with not flour even though
it's a bigger truck flours flammable
which is not a lot of people know I
don't actually know what it was but it's
still - kept us all very energized so
while we were filming in the hair this
is the little story I want to share up
front because it is yeah it's not
hazardous like that it was some sort of
compound that they made that we could
shoot it but it's unpleasant and to be
in there and sort of VIN was coming in
for his first day of shooting in there
we've done a bunch of like setups
working whatnot and it's unpleasant so
everyone's wearing like sort of the
equivalent of like a hazmat suit in
there and and oh my gosh can we can we
sort of maybe lose the mosque for a
minute or two it's very difficult to
convince someone to shoot in this for -
it was worth it
oh man
I should say that the idea for like the
flower I knew there was an attack on a
convoy and but I wanted to visually do
something that made it sort of iconic I
loved the sort of the red and white
colors of bloodshot but you know I
didn't know what I wanted to be and I
spent this sort of rather odd weekend on
YouTube looking at all these Russian
dashboard cam accidents and then I found
this one of this truck crashing into a
building a bakery truck and this flower
going everywhere and was even in that
sort of like little sort of lower is
sort of YouTube video it was remarkably
visually impressive so when we sort of
came upon time just to put it into it
into the scene of one of those moments
where you have something in your head
and you never quite know how it's going
to turn out and then it surpasses all
your expectations and you and it's just
the way
we reused JJ and Troy and Troy and
Johnny you and they had just come off of
John wick and they were so hell-bent on
trying to do something brand-new they
were coming they were asking us to be a
part of this because they felt there
could be some opportunity for a
different style of fighting there's a
viciousness to this that plays to the
character and it's not most superheroes
that have superhero powers you just kind
of rely on the fact that they can lift
up a car or something that the kind of
Titanic approach that the choreography
employs is what makes bloodshot color so
unique we work so hard that there were
injuries before we even started filming
but that was a testament to everybody's
commitment to really trying to make
something different and feel different I
can't tell you how many people have been
responding to how the action feels and
why it feels different and why it feels
appropriate for this kind of new launch
of a new way of telling the superheroes
my hunts that
[Music]
this was I think the very first shot we
actually developed the sort of movement
of the nanite sport
[Music]
so we pre visit the whole sequence and
then JJ like Ben said jay-z Perry came
in and then they sort of they had stunt
fares on top of that so it's sort of
rudimentary blocked out in previous and
we know the story we want to tell and
then JJ comes in and he adds all like
the sort of like that visceral quality
to the action that that Ben was talking
about and then and then on Liam once we
have our plates obviously we go in and
we start figuring out what the nanites
are gonna be that was and I prefer to
sort of look develop in in the context
in a shot that rather sort of been on a
blank slate we went through many
iterations but I overly prepare for
things so I had a ton of reference
material and the sort of almost a rubber
mattock of the movement of the nanites
that I wanted to so I gave that to Chris
Arun my visual effects supervisor and
sort of proposed this movement to them
and that was always I mean you've seen
like liquid metal and you've seen
healing before and you've seen all of
that so it was about creating something
that felt unique to bloodshot which was
the idea that like a billion little
things that are always working together
to serve like his agenda so there was
always like a particulate feel to -
they're sort of organized movement and
so that that took a long time which is
always on you know you're on a right
path when somebody's difficult to do and
there isn't like you can't just point at
something and say make it look like that
so it was a long process of discovery
I'd say took us maybe eight months
before that yeah I saw the first version
of that shot but we started like you
know why we were still filming to sort
of look develop it and then there was
you know there's that version of them
when we see them as particles and
there's the endoscopic version when you
actually get up close to them so there
was some multiple stages of they looked
about one oh man he did see
come on come on go on what he's here
they finished it and he's right bloody
here
this shot right here we did many many
times to get this right and it's very
difficult to do my first focus puller
Jimmy Johnson who's like the best in the
business is shooting completely blind I
like an 800 millimeter lens whether like
range of focus is half an inch and which
we were shooting in full and VIN is
running full tilt at the camera I'd like
I don't know how we got the shots at the
end of the day but it was one of the
game one of those moments where he sort
of emerged from the fog and you see it
in slow motion and you would just lay on
money the chest that you'll see this is
like is all all digital yes it was sort
of impossible to do as practically
I've been is too humble just every
single one of these is him like there
was not like I like this because it was
like this big personal moment way like
you feel like the films be building for
like 30 minutes to the scene like not
you know being on his back or not seeing
like the what is what he's going through
to achieve his objective would it be in
sort of travesty so to his testimony I
said he stayed four days in that
unpleasantness
so that one there with a sort of the
dropkicks the guy in the back of the car
most of the stunts were done practically
that's a dummy that we ratcheted in on
some Juarez and like just no one could
sustain it I don't think even the dummy
survived but it was it was a two-year to
your credit this was as much as
comfortable as you are with CGI you
opted to do this all same practical and
that's that's awesome I would say it
lays like other than like you know the
nanites in the face being yeah
yes like I mean the majority of stunts
yeah yeah the majority of scene is is
why removal it's amazing how little from
a visual effects that point we had to
spend sort of making us miss the scene
what it is it's awesome it's the moment
when when my job becomes what bloodshot
comes alive it's a kind of exciting
moment in the film and I'm looking back
at the significance of what I seen that
we just loved but now seeing it as the
first time bloodshot
recognizes who he is that's awesome
and we wanted to we had we had a whole
stunt Department that was determined to
make this like no other thing that
they've seen and there anyone seen and
everybody just worked so hard it shows
in the sequence but it's exciting yes
this makes me want to see the whole
movie right now
oh that's not good thank you for
watching that scene break down and be
sure to get your tickets
March 13th and get them on Fandango